why do you say you can't make the movie
you want
you have to make the movie that sells
yeah i
tend to believe that goes all the way up
the line
um
when i look at you look at place in
scorsese and coppola and people like
that i think they're making the same
kind of compromises in one or the other
because
ultimately there's first of all it's
just too many moving parts
to just make everything exactly like you
want
and there's too many chefs in the
kitchen
there's the actors that have their ideas
there's going to be the producers and
the distributors
and of course the filmmakers
are going to all have everybody has
their own ideas and so you have to make
something as close to
where you want it as possible
but i doubt that there's the perfect
movie that
ended up on the final cut
exactly the way it was intended to have
been made
um
it's really a it's really
a question of making sure that you get
the story that makes sense
and that
does what it's supposed to do
both creatively and financially that's
keeps you working
if you can
get
things done and
you know make whatever compromises you
need to make
but still
have a certain level of creative
integrity
and make the experience good for people
then
then that's how you continue to work and
i think that
it's an admirable goal to make the
perfect film you know make the film that
just one that we want to make
that doesn't have to
have the action scene in the first 10
minutes only
reason it would need the action scene in
the first 10 minutes if
our story requires it if it doesn't it
requires it many 20 30 it doesn't matter
so i think that we're all striving for
that
perfect film the way we see it in our
head
and
um
and sometimes it can be even a little
bit better
but rarely
it's always a little bit better in your
head than you than
than how it comes out
because it's just the nature of
the creative process the nature of the
collaborative process
makes it so it doesn't just all exist in
your
mind's eye
it has to go through
a lot a lot a lot of different people's
minds eyes
and
other resource-based things
and through the edit and the final cut
and the sound and everything else to the
point where
if you're lucky you can be surprised and
fear
have it be a another version of that
perfect film but
um
and
then it becomes
made perfect in its in its own unique
way but as far as it coming out
exactly the way it
exists in your head
i just don't think that that's um ever
going to happen
when you did your first film where you
were the producer did you already have a
distributor working with you no he did
not
we did that film
um
with private money
and we did not have a distributor
and
um if we would have i'm sure they would
have
told us to do certain things different
um probably put a little bit more action
in and things like that but when we had
it but once
we did this is what this is where you
get the
the
dream stuff
because once you have a movie like that
in the can people start to come at you
like they want to sell it and they tell
you all kinds of stuff we're going to
give you a four picture deal
you give us that movie and we're going
to give you a three picture first look
we're going to do all this stuff we're
going to get you this i have my my
friends over at william morris they're
going to sign you as a writer and
they're going to do all this stuff
once they get the movie
the first thing they do is
do a trailer and start selling it
and all that glamour you know
washes away you know because it's a
there's very few films that are attached
to nothing like that film was had no
distributor it was just a disk drive
with a movie with andy garcia and ray
leota and other people on it on the film
and everybody wanted it
and um so that's what blew our heads up
a little bit to think that we were on
this
you know amazing thing and you learn
like i said you learn those lessons
pretty quickly when they have this kind
of
kind of
less than
cool trailer i'm like what why would
they do a trail like that because all
they're doing is showing the action for
the foreign buyers
and so they're they're
i'm like well i didn't do the trailer
like the cool trailer i saw the
theatrical because and then of course
they tell your film's gonna go
theatrical we're gonna use all these
things with it this is gonna be great
it's the beginning of our relationship
and
you know sometimes that happens and
sometimes it doesn't
so for your second film did you have a
distributor already attached yes i did
it actually was the same distributor as
the first one so so let me be nice about
it but
um
we did and um
that i directed it and it was
a completely different experience
i was
you know i was kind of green as a
director
but i understood a lot of production
side stuff and i also understood a lot
of the editing stuff because i had done
a lot of editing on the first film
so
it was um
it was a lot different but there was a
distributor and the distributor had
already pre-sold it it just so happened
they pre-sold it to this little company
called blockbuster
the year they went out of business
so that order
went out
and
this is part of the
fall down and get up program here so um
so it didn't do as good as it was
supposed to do because there was it was
a design for blockbuster
so um
uh you know but it was a a beautiful
film and it was a good experience and
certainly learned a lot and
it's um you know i still consider it
probably the best piece that we've done
so you already saw it on the wall you
pictured yourself walking into the
blockbuster and or
one before
the film before lalina the line
was part of this blockbuster premiere
series that
it became the number four video in
blockbuster world nationwide and it had
this thing where they had this new thing
where they had they're gonna do a an
independent film and give it the same
space as a studio film and so it was a
program so they had bought placed the
orders for that program
and then they went out of business
we delivered in
uh
october that went out this is i think in
december
so they canceled it
but yeah you know like i said it was
still still a good movie we it gave us
the opportunity to make the film
um
and eventually it all worked out
why not just make the movie you want to
make
well i mean if i had the rich uncle or
if i was the rich uncle then i probably
could make it and i think i would i have
a script
a couple scripts that
i would just want to make exactly the
film the way it is
but you know
it
you know you have to make the decision
you want to keep working
and and keep um
and keep moving the career down the the
path
or do you want to you know create the
art that you want and i think that you
can find a balance in that
but
at this point you know you have to have
something to show you have to have a
reel you have to have
movies that you've done you've got a
[ __ ] in certain cases you have to show
numbers
um so you have to make the film
that you're able to make and
investors tend to like that distributors
tend to like that
more than hey i'm going to make the film
i want to make it it doesn't matter you
know if you make or lose your money we
we
try to do the film
as best we can and pepper in
all those beautiful moments and pepper
in all that beautiful cinematography but
at the end of the day we have to make
the films that people are
either giving us money to make or
you know that the market will bear
so
you know
i would
very much
like to do
a film just the way i see it
just the way every shot
i want to do it this way i want to do
the push in here i want to do the side
shot here but
sometimes there's always going to be
compromises in that
and so i think that
the key is to
make the film that you're making the
film you want to make
if you can find that balance
inside yourself and inside
the uh
the filmmaking experience and the and
the product i think that's more
a better way to try to kind of maybe
find it
love what you're doing find the maybe it
wasn't exactly what you saw but say
find the beauty and say that's amazing
and you have those moments and some
moments like well you know
a little bit less but you find the
moments and you do your best to string
those moments
together
and then still keep everybody happy so
that you can keep moving forward
the the true enemies
not moving forward
you have to keep making the films
and
you have to keep on
pushing
that
forward
put the little pieces onto your reel put
the little pieces onto experience learn
the pieces of information make those
contacts
then you move toward the more perfect
filmmaking experience that way
but that is
my opinion
the more safe trajectory i don't want to
call it safe but it's the more practical
one
to just
wait until say hey i want somebody to
get how brilliant this is
how brilliant this film will be
well what have you done well i've done
you know a couple shorts in a student
film okay
i'd rather show them
a vast
example of a lot of things that we've
done and they understand that we can get
things done so
and we can get things done efficiently
and and we can follow through and pivot
and be flexible and
bring things back from the brink of
disaster things like that and then
eventually you will get the faith and
confidence to
do something that
that is is that masterpiece i think
that's just one way to get to the
masterpiece i'm sure some people will
sit and wait and send it out enough
times and somebody will recognize it and
put money into it or whatever
but
for for me uh you just gotta take the
pieces of everything even if it's not
the best film you take the pieces that
are
show that and you move the program
forward
and the name of your second film that
was supposedly going to be in
blockbuster was it's called uh across
the line the exodus of charlie wright
now the thing is the distributor you
learn about distributors they always
want to put
some kind of
thing that was related to the original
movie which was across the line but the
name the original name was called the
exodus of charlie wright
so um
and i thought that was
the tone of the movie but they wanted to
put across the line in front of it so
that's that's fine
i i
got used to it eventually
pivot
do you think most people would have
given up after that experience so this
was like what you said your second film
you you came close to having it in
blockbusters unfortunately blockbuster
pivoted out of business
and
most people would have given up you said
you talked about having a long tail like
a body of work and not waiting
[Music]
a lot of people i know did or or you
know just felt folded back and kind of
waited for something to happen
um
some people would have quit and um
but but a lot of people wouldn't have i
mean
i think that um
you know
getting your films uh uh having some
sort of uh disappointment in film is is
just part of the business
and it's just and if you really can't
handle that
um especially you know
you know you can take a break
and and regroup
which we kind of did a little bit you
know take a break and regroup but but uh
if you give up after your second film
then you're probably not in the right
business to be honest with you you got
to keep got to keep it moving you got to
you got to really give it a certain
amount of time and just nothing
happening and then
you say okay well maybe this is
maybe i go back to selling insurance or
something but
you know you got to give it the old
college try
the way i look at it
is this
if i'm if i want to be a doctor
i can't go out if we're in 2022 i'm not
gonna be a doctor in 2023. it's going to
take me four years undergrad four years
med school then some other things
anything that's that's
that you really
that that it's meaningful
and and especially and there's a lot
more doctors than our directors anything
that's is complicated and
and and unique as being a director it's
not going to take
two years it's going to take 10 years 12
years and you shouldn't feel as though
the
some kind of failure or some sort of
disappointments aren't they're all part
of your school they're all part of
you know for undergrad then you're in
you've got to do it one way or the other
the world doesn't work that
you know you just wake up one day and
say i'm going to do this and just do it
you've got to go through the process and
and i think if you look at it like that
if you have that perspective
that i'm on year three
am i really supposed to be a big time
hot shot director well you know how the
media does they'll they'll show you
those people
but for every one of those people they
don't show you the hundreds of thousands
that didn't
do that
that didn't happen for
so
um i i always looked at it like it's
going to take a certain amount of time
what we're doing is a very unique thing
it's very sought after there's not that
many people that can do it
and it's going to take a certain amount
of time so just put in the time put in
the work get ready for the the hits
you know
learn the lessons and
then eventually you come out on
if you've got the talent
and the and the temperament
and the patience
and
um
the ability to to adjust
then you'll
then you know you can carve something
out for yourself and it'll just be to
what degree you carve it out so but i
think that you can if you can get
through that people will
trust you and give you a chance
yeah
and also there's a high degree of
skepticism that someone will be
a director whereas if someone takes the
proper
you know steps and they're in residency
and all these different things oh this
is this is so-and-so he's going to be a
doctor
whereas when
you introduce someone this is so-and-so
and he's going to be a director it's a
it's met with a different response at
least
absolutely
no it is because what because you know
it's just like i'm a writer a lot you
know but
what makes you a writer um
because in theory you have written i've
written 10 screenplays the question is
you know how many of the screenplays
have been produced
and
you know what makes i guess what makes a
difference between a writer a
professional writer and a successful
writer
you know are are three very
separate and unique things
and so when you talk about director
you know either you're directing films
or you're not you know
it's it's not about
prepping the film or developing it
or
writing a film and
you know putting together
the idea to do it you have to get on a
set and say roll sound
roll cameras action whatever that is
and then
and you but you've got it in but you
can't just stay and you know do it on
your iphone or on with your friends and
your buddies at some point you gotta
you've gotta you know get
yourself to the point where you can be
noticed and appreciated and someone to
look at you and say hey let's
i like what you do let's let's do a
little bit more of that
so
um
you know
you hear people say i'm a director i'm
an actor i'm a i'm a writer and good for
them you know maybe that's what they
need
to complete their process
and so that it makes sense for them so
but at the end of the day um you know
it's the market that
um dictates
where we sit in it
and our success
and so it's
about
understanding the balance between the
business and the art
understanding team building
understanding um
how to
put together the resources to keep
yourself working and things like that
will decide
um you know ultimately and
it's your real
you know what have you done your wheel
or your imdb and things like that that's
ultimately what you'll be judged by
so
you know um
you can talk
which is good like i said don't put
those people down they say hey i'm doing
this i'm doing that i'm writing i'm
directing i think great that's fantastic
but you gotta
actually get out there and get the work
done too
you must
so